[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenos días creen ustedes que son libres
creen que cuando deciden que comer
cuando deciden que estudiar o con quién
casarse verdaderamente deciden ustedes o
es el cerebro el que determina
absolutamente todo lo que hacemos todo
lo que decidimos y luego tenemos una
sensación de libertad que es tan solo
una ilusión
porque algunos neurocientíficos y
algunos divulgadores están diciendo que
en realidad el libre albedrío no existe
porque en que se basan cuáles son sus
pruebas el problema no es nuevo desde la
antigüedad la discusión filosófica va en
el sentido de decir que si todo tiene
que tener una causa física no puede
haber libertad esta frase tan dura se
puede romper de dos maneras los
compatibilice estás piensan que aún así
queda un cierto resquicio para la
libertad una libertad práctica una
libertad débil que habría surgido con el
advenimiento de la sociedad pero es el
libre albedrío débil es un determinismo
maquillado no nos gusta los libertarios
por su parte vienen a decir que habrá
que encontrar algo que no tenga una
causa física en que se basan que
experimentos han hecho los
neurocientíficos que están desentrañando
lo que es el cerebro humano dicen todo
lo que pensamos todo lo que sentimos
todo lo que recordamos tiene una base
física cuando lo hacemos redes
neuronales en nuestro cerebro se
disparan neuronas que en conjunto
contienen pensamientos sentimientos y
emociones
además cuando tenemos que decidir hay
muchas ideas que surgen en nuestra
cabeza sin nuestro control y muchas
veces la selección de alternativas
también parece inconsciente y al final
cuando finalmente decidimos que hacer
muchas veces parece que no hay causa
alguna que nos ha llevado a tomar esa
decisión
qué experimentos se han hecho para
estudiar los procesos de decisión
siempre procesos muy sencillos vamos a
mencionar el delibes de los años 80 por
su importancia histórica aunque es un
experimento muy muy sesgado lo que hizo
el ibex fue estudiar la actividad
eléctrica del cerebro cuando las
personas tomamos una decisión muy
sencilla levantar una mano y observó que
hasta medio segundo antes de que la
persona dijera que había tomado la
decisión el cerebro ya estaba en acción
para muchos espera una idea de que en
realidad la decisión se estaba fraguando
inconscientemente y después entraba en
nuestra consciencia dándonos esa
sensación de libertad
actualmente se utiliza la técnica de la
resonancia magnética funcional mucho más
precisa es una técnica de imagen que nos
permite ver el cerebro en acción
estudiamos las partes del cerebro
iluminadas por un mayor aporte de
oxígeno que están en funcionamiento ante
un estímulo highness pidió a sus
participantes que tomaran la decisión de
pulsar un botón con el índice de la mano
derecha o de la mano izquierda y observó
su cerebro
el resultado fue impresionante hasta
siete segundos antes de que el sujeto
reportará que había tomado la decisión
de usar el botón ya se observa una
actividad cerebral que en algunos casos
era predictiva jaime sabía que el botón
iba a pulsar que dedo iba a utilizar el
sujeto antes de que el mismo fuera
consciente para muchos esto fue un
modelo de decisión válida servía para
cualquier decisión humana y demostraba
que el libre albedrío era tan solo una
ilusión
hay más indicios como por ejemplo los
automatismos todos somos conscientes de
que la mayoría de lo que hacemos a lo
largo del día lo hacemos de forma
automática son hábitos que hemos
adquirido en el pasado y no los tenemos
que pensar o los condicionamientos quien
nos reconoce que está condicionado por
su educación por sus genes por su vida
incluso hay personas enormemente
condicionadas si son enfermos
enfermedades psiquiátricas los
psicópatas son libres les queda algo de
libertad o están totalmente determinados
frente a todo esto nos podemos sentir
desasosegados y nos preguntamos existe
esperanza de libertad de un libre
albedrío fuerte de verdad y creemos que
si para empezar desde el punto de vista
filosófico el emergente ismo nos viene a
dar una posible solución al problema de
la causa el emergente ismo se opone al
reduccionismo al decir que los sistemas
cuando se hacen más complejos
tienen propiedades nuevas que son reales
y que no se pueden explicar por las
propiedades de sus partes pensemos en un
animal pluricelular que tiene el sistema
digestivo cuesta mucho explicar los y
simplemente nos dedicamos a hablar de
las propiedades de sus células para
algunos estas propiedades no son en
realidad existentes son un defecto del
observador nuestra pobre capacidad de
cálculo y de sistematización pero para
otras las propiedades son reales y en el
ser humano tenemos una muy importante y
que tiene mucho que ver con la libertad
la conciencia que sepamos somos el único
ser vivo que tiene autoconsciencia y la
autoconsciencia podría ser una propiedad
real con causación descendiente es decir
a través de nuestra conciencia podríamos
modificar la arquitectura de nuestro
cerebro y eso significa tomar decisiones
y solventar el problema de la causa pero
hay más
desde la ciencia sabemos que desde 1927
cuando boehner heisenberg anunció su
principio de incertidumbre el mundo no
está totalmente determinado el
determinismo absoluto ya no es
defendible elin determinismo nos dice
que por lo menos en el nivel subatómico
las partículas
cuando tienen que colapsar a uno de dos
estados no se puede saber a cuál van a
colapsar no es un problema de falta de
cálculo de observación es que es
indecidible no se puede saber esos
fenómenos se observan bien en los átomos
en las cosas muy pequeñas pero no los
percibimos en nuestro mundo a nuestra a
nuestra escala podrán afectar los
fenómenos de indeterminación los
procesos biológicos podrán afectar los
procesos de sinapsis en el cerebro
algunos piensan que si por ejemplo peter
se tiene un modelo denominado causalidad
criteria al según el cual el disparo de
las neuronas también está sujeto a la
indeterminación y aunque no pudiéramos
cambiar el resultado de una decisión del
presente si podríamos modificar los
requisitos que han hecho que esas
neuronas se disparen de manera que en el
futuro la decisión puede tener un
resultado diferente
son modelos que plantean nuevos nuevos
interrogantes por ejemplo cómo se
produce esa amplificación cómo sube ese
fenómeno de terminación cuántica hasta
el nivel biológico y cómo de alguna
manera pierde su aleatoriedad jones
serles un filósofo que desde hace
algunos años ha abrazado la
indeterminación cuántica como una puerta
abierta a la libertad porque él dice es
la única que tenemos según sale hay dos
hipótesis cuando decidimos hay dos
niveles el nivel neurobiológico lo que
está sucediendo en nuestro cerebro y el
nivel de nuestra consciencia lo que
percibimos todos tenemos la sensación de
que en la conciencia las cosas son
discontinuas es decir que hay momentos
en los que podemos tirar hacia un lado
tirar hacia otro pero dice serles si lo
que está sucediendo en el nivel
neurobiológico es un continuo si es una
concatenación de causas físicas una
detrás de otra como una maquinaria en
realidad eso está determinando nuestra
consciencia y es tan sólo una ilusión
y hay otra hipótesis de trabajo quizá en
el nivel neurobiológico también hay
discontinuidades y tienen que venir de
los fenómenos cuánticos de la
indeterminación serles consciente de que
esto plantea estas dos grandes grandes
interrogantes y dos grandes desafíos que
es explicar como los procesos cuánticos
ascienden hasta el nivel biológico y
desde luego no queremos una libertad que
pase de ser determinista a ser aleatoria
de alguna manera en ese ascenso se tiene
que conservar la indeterminación pero
perder la aleatoriedad
lo que es cierto es que el cerebro
cambia con la vida eso se puede ver en
las pruebas de imagen viejas sinapsis
viejas redes neuronales se desactivan y
surgen otras nuevas pero evidentemente
es un proceso que cuesta energía y que
se va perdiendo con los años es la
neuroplasticidad esto nos lleva a una
idea muy importante la libertad hay que
trabajarla no se tiene per se y todo el
mundo tiene la misma durante toda la
vida la tendencia es cada vez a dejar el
cerebro adormecido haciendo las mismas
rutinas de siempre utilizando las mismas
redes neuronales es lo que menos
esfuerzo menos energía cuesta pero hay
personas que son capaces de mantener
siempre el pensamiento abierto de
mantener su capacidad de cambio
capacidad de pensar de otra manera de
actuar de otra manera y eso significa
procesos de cambio de arquitectura
cerebral si somos nosotros con nuestra
consciencia a los que hacemos eso los
que somos agentes de ese cambio ahí
podríamos tener una prueba de libertad
pero hay que trabajarla hay que
trabajarla cada día de la vida
nos habíamos quedado con unos
experimentos de genes que nos dejaban
asombrados podemos darles otra
explicación los experimentos científicos
nos dan unos datos son incontrovertibles
son indiscutibles las interpretaciones
es donde realmente entra el pensamiento
y la subjetividad de cada cual highness
vio que 7 segundos antes había actividad
en algunas zonas del cerebro pero 7
segundos es un tiempo enorme el ser
humano no podría sobrevivir en el mundo
si para cada decisión por pequeña que
fuera tendría que tuviera que tardar
siete segundos o incluso menos todos
somos conscientes de que tomamos
decisiones mucho más deprisa que puede
ser el hecho de estas iluminaciones del
cerebro durante ese tiempo quizá tengan
otra explicación quizá no fueron
procesos decisorios sino de otro tipo a
los que participaron en el experimento
se les instruyó para no pensar en nada
pero eso es muy difícil
algunas personas seguro que hicieron
planes todos los que hemos jugado a
pares y nones a piedra papel tijera
sabemos que hacemos estrategias pensamos
cuántas veces hemos hecho una cosa
cuántas veces la otra
y aunque nos hayan entrenado en no
pensar en nada es muy difícil hacerlo
quizá algunos de los participantes
hicieron sus estrategias y precisamente
las zonas que se iluminaron corresponden
con zonas del cerebro que se utilizan
para trazar planes y para grabarlos
quizá fueron esos los poquitos que nos
siguieron las instrucciones los que
hicieron planes y por tanto el equipo de
resonancia lo vio y fue predictivo y así
subió un poco el porcentaje de aciertos
sobre el 50 por ciento del azar se subió
hasta un 60 por ciento es una
explicación posible por supuesto no
segura pero que no todo necesariamente
tiene que ser determinismo y respecto al
hecho de que todo esté en las neuronas
por supuesto que si esto no nos tiene
qué desasosegar nos movemos porque
nuestros músculos se mueven pensamos
porque nuestras neuronas se conectan es
lógico pero si al final al tomar una
decisión no somos capaces de encontrar
una causa física para la misma porque
decidir que eso es un indicio en contra
de la libertad a la libertad habría que
concederle la presunción de inocencia
también el que quiera demostrar que eso
implica que la libertad no existe que se
ponga la tarea
porque está precisamente en la falta de
causa es donde se encuentren nuestro
libre albedrío
con todo lo dicho nos podemos preguntar
qué es lo que mueve a algunos a decir
que la libertad no existís también se
basan en otra cuestión por ejemplo en el
hecho de que la gente esté condicionada
pero las condiciones a veces nos hablan
en favor y no en contra de la libertad
pensemos lo que sucede con las personas
que padecen el síndrome
obsesivo-compulsivo son personas que se
obsesionan con algo hay muchos tipos de
obsesiones lavarse las manos comprobar
que han cerrado la puerta de casa muchas
veces etcétera todas dicen que han
perdido su libertad es un indicio muy
interesante la libertad todos sentimos
que la tenemos y si la perdemos nos
damos perfecta cuenta porque no tienen
libertad de estas personas porque no
tienen automatismos porque tienen que
dedicar su atención a las cosas que los
demás hacemos de forma automática y eso
le resta libertad los automatismos no
nos quitan libertad todo lo contrario
son cosas que en decisiones hechas en el
pasado hemos pasado a modo automático se
las hemos encargado a nuestro cerebelo
para poder dedicar la poca atención que
tenemos la poca capacidad de atención y
de
recibir datos que tenemos a las cosas
que nos importan a las cosas importantes
e interesantes pero como decía que les
puede mover a tantos neurocientíficos a
decir que el libre albedrío no existe
porque en principio todos deberíamos
preferir ser libres los abogados
defensores de la libertad deberíamos ser
todos no quizás son otras causas otras
razones las que les llevan a actuar así
para empezar vender libros porque la
idea de libertad está tan en realizada
en el ser humano que si decimos somos
libres a nadie le extraña pero si
decimos somos máquinas de carne es una
idea sorprendente transgresora y
evidentemente hace mucho más fácil
vender libros pero además quizá haya dos
grandes piezas que estas personas pueden
estar intentando cazar por una parte la
responsabilidad moral
qué sentido tiene castigar a nadie de lo
que hace si no es responsable si está
determinado si ha sido su cerebro no ha
actuado mal él dice es su cerebro el que
el hacha actuará si está mal cableado
también qué sentido tiene de dar más
recompensa a unos que a otros si al
final todo el mundo actúa por lo que por
los dictados de su cerebro pero la
responsabilidad moral a la hora del
castigo está enraizada en otros fines
dos principios en la sociedad
incluso los los compatibilice está si
los deterministas puros que traba
en el asunto que son juristas se dan
cuenta que el debate sobre liberal
no tiene nada que ver con la
responsabilidad moral que está cimentada
sobre la psicología social y sobre el
contrato de las sociedades muy pocas
sociedades entenderían que un depredador
sexual grave se le pasará por una
pequeña reacondicionamiento cerebral y
no pisará la cárcel por tanto estos
debates a veces están enormemente
viciados quizá la otra cuestión que
estas personas puedan intentar atacar
son las religiones es evidente que para
las grandes religiones pues no parece
muy compatible que en este mundo exista
un dios bondadoso que nos haya situado
en él y que en el fondo nos tratemos
solamente de pequeños juguetes
automáticos pero en cualquier caso es
como lo vemos el mundo tiene dos grandes
bis y cosmovisiones
por una parte podemos pensar que todo es
un conjunto de partículas sin
pensamiento y sin sentido que por algún
motivo se van organizando en sistemas
cada vez más complejos hasta llegar a
dar cosas como el propio ser humano por
otra la sensación de que somos seres
y racionales inteligentes que tenemos
una bizet y acá que tenemos una bis
política y que somos libres y capaces de
tomar decisiones
de momento no tenemos pruebas no es
verdad que la ciencia haya demostrado en
este sentido pero tenemos indicios
tenemos caminos abiertos tenemos el
camino de la indeterminación cuántica
que nos abre esa puerta hacia lanzar
como condición necesaria pero no
suficiente para la libertad y tenemos
desafíos tenemos que conseguir saber qué
es la conciencia tenemos conseguir
conseguir ver cómo los fenómenos de
indeterminación afectan a nuestro
pensamiento y cómo se pierde la
aleatoriedad pero tenemos más indicios
indicios de que todos sentimos la
libertad y las sentimos desaparecer
cuando enfermamos cuando tenemos
trastornos y algunos indicios
enormemente bellos como los actos de
personas que en contra de su
supervivencia en contra de su
preservación incluso dan la vida por
salvar a veces a alguien al que ni
siquiera conocen
traigo esta foto de nuestro héroe del
patria ignacio echeverría que fue
abatido a tiros por un terrorista en
2017 cuando intentaba salvar a una
persona que no conocía para los
deterministas fue un acto automático no
tuvo tiempo de deliberar posiblemente
cierto pero por qué no pensar que
realmente ignacio en ese momento hacia
un resumen de su vida entera toda una
vida de decisiones para construir una
serie de valores una forma de pensar una
forma de entregarse a los demás y se
preparó para poder resultar en esa
decisión en aquel momento se preparó
todos los años de su vida y no tuvo
mucho que pensar simplemente se lanzó y
perdió su vida haciendo algo que cuesta
mucho creer que ningún animal hiciera
el debate está abierto los experimentos
de la ciencia del futuro serán
apasionantes pero no nos resistiremos a
pensar que el ser humano es un ser libre
con una libertad fuerte porque la
libertad humana es en mi opinión el
valor más bello del ser humano muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]